it here but i wonder if you guys are
also
possibly familiar with the band yes
yeah and yes from the 70s 80s yeah and
even you know still playing
um so they had one
yes had one number one song
owner of a lonely heart owner of a
lonely heart
yeah it sounds just like that but here
here's a here's a little clip
this is my job in high school
once they make this video are they bad
bedroom
hey that beat is crazy yeah
that's a great beat but they made a
video in a bedroom
so the guy the guy playing lead guitar
there yeah
trevor rabin trevor raven is his name
okay
and you know what else trevor rabin is
is famous for
was that we're not sure this song
he made are you serious yes oh trevor
way back
in a round 2002 2003.
he uh he came up with the uh with the
theme song and trevor joyce from los
angeles
hey trev uh hi hey how are you
i'm good how you doing hey we number one
we thank you so much for your work
on composing that theme music because
man it has staying power
and uh it is just immediately
recognizable as saying hey the nba on
tnt is on
how did you come up with the idea what
drove what drove you to that
um as as far as the aggression goes i
remember
when kurt rambis was kirtline
um clothe line by kevin mccabe
kevin mchale and so the beginning of it
was kind of
the aggression that hopefully that
brought but uh i really just wanted to
write a theme that would be memorable
and broke some
uh barriers that you know were always
there for
kind of sports teams and brought some
rock and roll into it and
obviously used the orchestra as well so
let me ask you a question
uh was it specifically made for us or
you had it working on another song
no it was specifically done for for the
show
and it was great i had i had such fun
doing it
it's funny because um i do film scores
and one of the movies i did was a film
remember the titans with denzel
washington oh yeah and i wrote the music
for that and i think that's what led
them to
asking me to do this and uh i jumped at
it because i love basketball i've been a
fan for years
so how many times have you played and
performed owner of a lonely art
think you've reached a million times yet
well i
probably uh 500 times when i was writing
it
but since then thousands of times on the
road
um yeah in fact
i remember one concert i did we were
playing the summit and
the night before we were at the hotel
and i saw charles walking through
because
i guess you were playing in you were
playing in houston and
we played the next night you won
well my question is you know as a great
songwriter composer
would there be a melody to that tnt song
and if it had
a hook what would it be
oh boy that's a good question i have to
think about that
basically i just write lyrics over the
the theme that it is
and uh maybe i can use some croatian
uh hey trevor i got a question for you
what's
better writing a great song
or singing a great song
i think the writing is uh the most
satisfying thing but you know being on
the road is something which is
always just being so great such such
such a thrill
yeah hey and we we appreciate it and we
encourage folks to also check out the
new york times article by uh sopon
deb profiled uh trevor the other day and
talked about
the history of uh of the theme song and
uh
it's great to put a face with the music
trevor thank you so much for your great
work and uh you've kind of given us the
signature
the signature music for our show for as
long as a lot of us have been here we
appreciate that thank you
thank you so much it was great fun
trevor raven
the man who composed you know what's
really interesting about the theme songs
musicians
yeah every basketball player want to be
a musician
did you want to be a musician i want to
be able to sing uh that never happened
can we play that a little louder out one
more time yeah that's a raptor inside
the nba